today on the matt wall show after
overcoming the coronavirus trump tells
americans
not to be afraid of the virus and not to
let it dominate our lives
the media doesn't like this message very
much but it's it's exactly what people
need to hear i think and my own personal
recent experience proves it i'll explain
why also five headlines including
more stunning revelations from the
melania tapes only they aren't the sort
of revelations
that the left wants and in our daily
cancellation we'll talk about the
not at all shocking conclusion to the
althea bernstein alleged hate crime case
that's a case that we've been following
on this show
it has come to a conclusion you're never
going to guess um
we'll talk about all of that on the way
and much more but first
you know i've been telling you about our
friends at rock auto for a long time and
for a good reason everyone has car
related expenses that pop up everyone is
looking for the easiest and most
affordable options to deal with that and
rockauto.com
is that option i'm telling you you just
have to give it a try rockauto.com is
always
going to be so much easier and
ultimately faster than walking into a
store
you know you have someone demanding
quick answers to questions about your
car you might not know the answers to
the questions
and they usually they just have to order
the part online anyway because there are
so many types of cars it's impossible to
keep them all stocked you have access to
rockauto.com
at your desk in your pocket which means
in a certain sense you can fit more
parts auto parts in your pocket than the
store can in the whole building because
you got your phone there
rockauto.com offers the lowest prices
possible rather than changing prices
uh based on you know what they think
they can charge you go to rockauto.com
the shop for auto and body parts from
hundreds of manufacturers best of all
prices at rockauto.com cannot stress
this enough are always reliably low
and they're the same no matter if you're
a professional or do-it-yourselfer why
spend up to twice as much for the same
parts there's no reason to the
rockauto.com
catalog is unique and easy to to
navigate you could quickly see all the
parts available for your car
truck and you could choose the brand
specifications whatever you want
that you prefer amazing selection
reliably low prices
all the parts your car will ever need go
to rockauto.com
rockauto.com right now see all the parts
available for your car truck and
remember to write walsh in there how did
you hear about us box
so that they know that we sent you okay
well
donald trump uh returned from the
hospital after
three days being treated for the
coronavirus i don't know if you heard
about that by the way donald trump
had the coronavirus sort of a a fringe
news event
modestly reported in any case he
returned
and from the reaction on the part of the
left-wing media you'd almost
think that they were i don't know upset
that the president united states
recovered from his illness
there certainly wasn't much in the way
of relief um
much less celebration upon his return
instead there was a lot of a lot of
stuff like this this is from chris cuomo
on cnn
very angry that trump appeared on the
balcony
after returning home to wave to the
crowd here's what cuomo had to say
he didn't just walk into the white house
one time with no mass tonight he had his
video crew capture that
stupid scene again so he could put out
propaganda
fronting a lie to his people once again
just like
don't worry about the mass now he says
don't worry about kovac don't let it
control your life
just propaganda that's all it is
i know this sound to it i'm not going to
play it for you why should i
how much [ __ ] do you need in your
life now this of course
is coming from the guy who had coveted
himself and
claimed he was quarantined in his
basement but was apparently gallivanting
around town
cuomo is you know worried about
propaganda and and lies and bs
as he eloquently puts it but he's also
the person who staged his own
re-emergence from quarantine
filmed it for tv even though he'd
already been out of quarantine
apparently
then as a side note that the funniest
thing about that stunt from cuomo if you
remember that video
was the the visible ambivalence from his
wife and children
about the fact that dad had escaped from
the basement they didn't seem very happy
to have him up there
maybe they were ambivalent more about
the phony pageantry than anything else
but still
uh it was pretty funny so that's cuomo
that's what he has to say
uh the media reaction though got a lot
more unhinged than that
and we're not going to waste time
showing a million examples you can kind
of imagine
just one more this is from maureen dowd
she says
when trump walked through the doors
walter reed had a stellar reputation
that's the hospital
trump was being treated at as he walks
out 20 72 hours
later its reputation is in tatters
there's nothing trump can't ruin she
says its reputation is in tatters
because it successfully treated the
president united states and got him on
his way and back home in three days
that's going to ruin their reputation
jennifer rubin a professional insane
person
now wants walter reed to be defunded she
says
defunded for committing the crime of
helping the president
not die from the chronovirus as i said
it's
almost as if these people are unhappy
that donald trump recovered you'd be
forgiven for arriving at that conclusion
is all i'm saying now
trump himself had a message for the
people upon his return to the
land of the living and i thought his
message was better than what we're
getting from the media here's what he
had to say
i just left walter reed medical center
and it's really
something very special the doctors the
nurses the first responders
and i learned so much about coronavirus
and one thing that's for certain don't
let it
dominate you don't be afraid of it
you're going to beat it we have the best
medical equipment we have the best
medicines
all developed recently and you're going
to beat it i went
i didn't feel so good and two days ago i
could have left two days ago two days
ago i felt great like
better than i have in a long time i said
just recently
better than 20 years ago don't let it
dominate don't let it take over your
lives
don't let that happen we have the
greatest country in the world
we're going back we're going back to
work we're going to be out front
as your leader i had to do that i knew
there's danger to it but i had to do it
i stood out front i led nobody that's a
leader
would not do what i did and i know
there's a risk there's a danger but
that's okay
and now i'm better and maybe i'm immune
i don't know
but don't let it dominate your lives get
out there
be careful we have the best medicines in
the world
and it all happened very shortly and
they're all getting approved
and the vaccines are coming momentarily
thank you very much and walter reed what
a group of people thank you very much
now he reiterated this main point in a
tweet saying i'll be leaving the great
walter reed medical center today at 6 30
p.m feeling really good don't be afraid
of covid don't let it dominate your life
we have developed under the trump
administration some really great drugs
and knowledge i feel better than i did
20 years ago
okay so that that's been his message
don't be afraid don't let it dominate
your life
now i'm not gonna be the guy to sit here
and tell you that the white house's
response to trump's coveted diagnosis
has been brilliant
or even vaguely competent or coherent
even but
this messaging right here okay these two
sentences
are absolutely what trump should be
saying and what all of our leaders
if they actually care about leading
should be saying
don't be afraid don't let it dominate
your life
live your life live like a normal human
being maintain your dignity and your
sanity
or reclaim them if you've already
forfeited them this is the message that
trump should carry into the election
don't be afraid we used to we used to
want our leaders to say stuff like that
don't be afraid
this is a message that is especially
necessary now as states like new york
contemplate going back into lockdown
mode though they never really
left lockdown mode in the first place
yesterday governor cuomo of new york
held a press conference where he
specifically threatened to
close down religious institutions if
they don't bend to his will
listen to this if
we're going to keep religious
institutions open
it can only be with two conditions
one the community must
agree whether it's the jewish community
whether we're talking about black
churches whether we're talking about
roman catholic churches the religious
community has to agree
to the rules and they have to agree
that they are going to follow the rules
and they have to agree that they are
going to be a full partner
in the enforcement of the rules
that's condition one i'm going to meet
with
members of the ultra orthodox community
tomorrow i want to have that
conversation directly myself
this cannot happen again if you do not
agree
to enforce the rules then we'll close
the institutions down
i am prepared to do that cuomo of course
continuing to operate on the premise
that the first amendment isn't a thing
the first amendment doesn't exist
or it does exist but it's it's
automatically neutralized
null and void whenever people are scared
of getting sick but you know as some of
us have been arguing for months
that is not actually how the
constitution works the
unless people are scared of getting sick
clause is not written anywhere in the
document
and though i haven't checked i'm
assuming it wasn't written in invisible
ink either
you know maybe you need a special
decoder ring or something that you
find at the bottom of a crackerjack box
to see it but i tend to doubt that
theory
you know and this is made all the more
unconstitutional blatantly absurdly
unconstitutional
when you consider that religious
institutions are being specially
targeted as
mass gatherings while the mass
gatherings of blm supporters are ignored
or even encouraged by these very same
leaders
you know we damn sure haven't heard
cuomo or any other democrat governor
threaten to
close down blm protests have you heard
them say that no
if they did all the people cheering for
the forcible shuttering of churches
would suddenly discover a renewed love
of the first amendment of that we can be
sure
now why is this being tolerated
well because because of fear trump is
right people are terrified and fear is
irrational it is always irrational to
some extent in this case a very great
extent
we can see the evidence of irrational
fear you know we could see it plain as
day because people wear it on their
faces
even as the who announces as it did this
week the world health organization
that 10 of the world's population may
have already been infected by the virus
making the already low mortality rate
much much lower still even as this
additional evidence emerges
that the virus is not as deadly as we
were first told
um still masks seem to be
becoming only more common not less
it's not that every person who wears a
mask is scared you know i wear them when
i go to the grocery store because
they won't let me in the building unless
i do and i need groceries
but it seems many americans are getting
comfortable with them
you know just wearing them all the time
often for no discernible reason
the polls do reflect this a national
geographic poll released today
finds that 92 percent of americans say
they wear a mask
when they leave their homes 74 say they
always do
always wear a mask when they leave their
home
now this poll is somewhat vague and
leaves open some questions you know when
they say
they always wear masks when they leave
their home do they mean they put it on
when they exit their front door and
don't take it off until they walk back
in it
so like in the car walking on the
sidewalk etc
walking down their driveway they wear
masks for that too
i don't know and how many of the 92
percent or the 74 percent
are doing this because they want to and
how many are forced to by local
ordinances
we don't know exactly but anecdotal
evidence suggests that a certain
significant portion of americans
do in fact by choice eagerly and
willingly
wear a mask literally everywhere they go
now
i have noticed this myself in the last
two weeks i've taken my family to the
beach
and up into the mountains on different
days we've been doing a lot of driving
mainly because we need to get out of the
house for showings and inspections and
things
as we prepare to make the move to
nashville uh so we've been going all
over the place but
i can report that in both places on the
beach and up in the mountains 600 miles
apart
i saw plenty of people wearing masks and
i just want to emphasize
so you understand we were hiking on a
mountain
in the woods and there were people in
the woods
hiking with surgical masks on who were
they worried about infecting or getting
infected by the trees a squirrel
me well i never came within 30 yards of
these people
like i said the woods are a pretty big
place you can
easily maintain a very comfortable
distance from people
coronavirus are not that you know that's
part of the whole point of going for a
hike right to get some space
breathe the open air only these people
instead of breathing the mountain air or
the ocean air
we're breathing their own sweaty fumes
and this is supposed to be safer
healthier more in keeping with the
science let me ask you
what science tells us that you stand any
significant risk
of getting infected or infecting someone
else while hiking on a trail in the
woods
or sitting on the beach or driving in
your car by yourself
or walking down the sidewalk have there
been any confirmed cases of
anyone anywhere contracting the virus in
any of those settings
i mean of the millions of hundreds of
millions of cases according to who
has there been one single confirmed case
of someone
contracting it when they're outside and
just maybe
walking by someone several feet away or
even a couple of feet away
i'm not aware of any such confirmed case
and if it did happen it's an extreme
extreme outlier now you might respond
that sure the chances of contracting or
spreading coven when you're
going for a walk in the woods or doing
any of these other activities is very
very very very low
but it's not impossible it could happen
sure it could happen it could also
happen that a tiny space rock flies out
of the sky
hits you in the head yet you don't wear
a helmet everywhere do you
it could happen that you trip and bash
your knees on the ground yet you don't
wear knee pads everywhere
in fact even before covet there were
plenty of airborne illnesses that you
could you could have contracted could
have
maybe did contract yet you never wore a
mask before
so why now and don't tell me that covet
is more dangerous than the flu or
whatever else it might be or might not
be depending on your demographic
but even if it is the point is that
before kovid
it's not that you took fewer precautions
or wore the mask a little less often
it's that you did nothing at all and
wore the mask
not at all ever and now you wear it all
the time
and take a million precautions as
opposed to zero
something is out of balance here
perspective has been completely lost
now why do i care you know why not just
let people wear the mask all day if they
want to
wear them to bed wear it in the shower
why not let them do that well well
they're free to do that i'm not
preventing them nor do i seek to
but i care because it's irrational and
embarrassing
and undignified and this is not the kind
of society i want to live in
let me show you one other thing speaking
of undignified and
then we'll get to the news but here's a
clip from a funeral service in the uk
it's a grieving widow mourning the loss
of her husband
her sons move in closer to comfort her
and then and then watch what happens
next
it's my privilege to have been asked to
conduct our service today to celebrate
the life of alan wright
i therefore offer you all a very warm
welcome as we unite in love
and friendship to
now let's put aside the fact that the
fear of the chronovirus is largely out
of balance and out of perspective even
if it wasn't
even if the virus was as deadly as many
people seem to think it is
what you just saw there would still be
outrageous
and wrong and disgraceful i don't care
if it had a mortality rate of 70 percent
her sons move in to comfort her and
someone comes into to separate them and
scold them telling them to maintain
social distance from their grieving
mother
what we're watching here is the total
forfeiture of basic
dignity and decency and humanity and
forfeiting that because you're scared is
not okay it's never okay it's cowardice
and it's a fool's bargain in the end
anyway because we're all gonna die
we're all mortal none of us will leave
this life alive no matter what happens
you whoever is listening right now you
will almost certainly be dead in 70
years
at most probably much sooner your body
will decay in the ground
you will be eaten by worms it will
happen
and the thing that kills you will almost
certainly not be the coronavirus
whatever it is though
that does you in ultimately do you want
to face that demise a demise that was
always inevitable that was always going
to happen
that you could never have escaped anyway
knowing that you lived your life in fear
that you lived without dignity in order
to avoid this very moment that is that
was always going to come anyway
is that what you want is that what
anyone wants
i don't think so like this is not a call
for us to throw caution to the wind or
be reckless or suicidal
it's just a call for us to live our
lives and have just a little bit of
courage and a little bit of perspective
and to let sons comfort their grieving
mothers and parents go to work to feed
their families
and religious people go to their houses
of worship to praise their god
and it's a call to take the mask off
every once in a while and breathe the
open air
because one day you're not going to be
able to anymore so don't give up these
small human joys
before you have to that's my point
let's get to our five headlines
[Music]
you know it's difficult these days to
find companies that offer a great
service but also
uh are are you know in keeping with our
values
so that we can support a good cause and
also a good company at the same time
it's difficult as conservatives to do
that especially as pro-lifers you know
it could be very hard
but that's why i'm so grateful we have
the pro-life phone company that is
charity mobile
um you know charity mobile five percent
of your monthly plan goes to the
pro-life
pro family charity of your choice so
that means that you're you know you're
just paying your
your phone bill but you're also
supporting
a cause that's important to you so it's
not just it's just not it's not just
that charity mobile is
is is not objectionable like they're
they're not actively undermining
um our cause and the culture it's that
they're actively helping it you know
now uh new there's a there's a lot of
other great stuff about this company new
activations and
eligible accounts get a free cell phone
with free activation free shipping
um there's no contracts there's no
termination fees there's no risk with a
30-day guarantee you also get that live
customer
service based in the usa you get a lot
of other benefits too
you could you can block the use of
cellular data you picture messages text
messages on any and all
lines in your account you get free usage
alerts you get a free app
to monitor your usage you can pay your
bill and more
a lot of great benefits a great service
in fact i was um speaking of being up in
the woods i was you know we were up in
the mountains as part of the country
would go to a lot because
my wife's family's up there and usually
before i had charity mobile
with my other phone i could never get
reception up in that
up there and uh and i was getting great
reception even out in the woods
my wife wasn't necessarily so happy
about that but but you know i thought it
was great to get that good reception
you can help build a culture of life in
america while supporting a pro-life
company
uh turn every day living into effortless
giving for the charity of your choice
you could call charity mobile this is
what i'd recommend call them at
1-877-474-3662
or chat with them online at
charitymobile.com all right
so i was i was away uh when this big
bombshell dropped
big big bombshell the biggest
bombshelliest
bombshell of them all but fortunately
you know um i could
still weigh in because just last night
there was another there was another
bombshell related to this another
development
we'll talk about that in a second i'm
referring of course to uh the melania
tapes melania trump
the first lady used to be friends with a
vile wretch of a woman named stephanie
winston
wolkov and i only call her that because
i call her a vile wretch of a woman
because she was secretly recording for a
period of time
secretly recording her friend and you
know i would say that secretly recording
someone who
you claim to be your friend so that you
can give the tapes to the media later
i think that qualifies you for the vile
wretch camp personally
um and uh let's so so the
the the the first tape that came out
this was last week
you probably heard the first one but
let's play it again anyway this was the
um
tape that was released a few days ago
media is making a big deal of it but
here's what was said
they say i'm completed i'm the same like
him i support him i don't say enough i
don't do enough
you know where i am that i put i'm
working like a ass my ass i know
christmas stuff that you know
who gives a [ __ ] about christmas stuff
and decoration but i need to do it right
yeah but a hundred percent you have no
choice
and okay and then i do it and i said
that i'm working on christmas uh
planning for the christmas
and they said oh what about the children
that they were separated
give me a break
where they were saying anything when
obama did that i know
i cannot go i i was trying
to get the kid reunited with the mom
i didn't have a chance needs to go
through the process and through the law
but here's my thing hear what you just
said but instead of that
if if you just your messaging
you you were so loved not do the story
we put it out they would not do the
story
until you would not believe it they
would not
do the story because no they are not
they would not do the story because they
they are
they are against us because they are
liberal media
yeah if i go to fox they will do the
story i don't want to go to fox
so that tape is supposed to prove
something i don't know exactly
i don't know what they thought it proves
what it proves to me
is that melania is much nicer and more
buttoned up than a lot of people are in
private including me
okay she was being recorded by a trusted
confidant
and that's the worst thing they caught
her saying was that
you know it has to be the worst there
are a lot of tapes out there but they're
going to lead with their
their the biggest one the worst one
they're going to lead with that
and that's it i'll just tell you this
if a trusted confidant was recording me
secretly for weeks on end um you would
hear
a lot worse than that a lot worse
i can tell you and that's the irony is
that both trump
and his wife have been secretly recorded
by people they trusted
for trump it was michael uh cohen and
somehow
they weren't caught saying anything
horrible
they're actually it would seem they are
less offensive in their private lives
than the average american that was the
surprising thing from
for me with with the trump tapes
especially is that he's actually
he's more outrageous in public than he
is in private
um so what do you hear in that tape
melania complains about the media
rightfully so
um you know because they refuse to cover
the good things that she and her husband
are doing she's complaining about that
she complains about christmas
decorations
the left tried to make that into a oh
she's waging a war on christmas oh
please
who doesn't complain about christmas
complaining about christmas decorations
is a time-honored american tradition
it's as american as as blue jeans and
drive-throughs it's it's the most
american thing in the world
we that's this is what we do we put up
the christmas decorations and we
complain about them
we complain about them while we're
putting them up
anyone who ever grew up you know
watching their dad hang the christmas
lights
outside you can attest to this all the
colorful language that came out of your
dad's mouth as he was trying to hang the
christmas lights
um and so that was the first thing uh
the worst thing she did was she
complained about
christmas decorations then last night
another tape was dropped this one
is even at this one's probably even more
shockingly unshocking than the first
this is what you said listen
uh annie label shot the porn
hooker and she will be one of the issues
september or october
what do you mean she shot the porn
hooker
stormy yeah and that's it she refers to
stormy daniels as a porn hooker
which she is it's a pretty decent
uh description
and that's it there's no there's really
not much else to it than that
i i gotta i'm i am really really
surprised i
i just sort of assume can you imagine
okay what if there were michelle tapes
what if michelle obama had been secretly
recorded
by her most trusted ally and friend in
secret
for you know for weeks what kind of
stuff do you think we'd hear
i'm thinking probably worse stuff than
i don't want to hang the christmas
decorations um all right
here's another story that i missed last
week that i have to circle back
and uh and talk about reading from the
website discern headline navy seals
changes creed to be gender neutral
removes brotherhood
other gendered language it says u.s navy
seals
and the navy special warfare combatant
craft crewmen have
recently changed their ethos and creed
to be gender neutral
removing gendered words like brotherhood
according to naval special warfare
spokesman uh
lieutenant commander matthew stroup in
an emailed statement to american
military news one of the changes to the
seal ethos is an
altered sentence that says common
citizens with uncommon desire to succeed
instead of the original a common man
with uncommon desire to succeed
then he goes on to explain today says
naval special warfare continues to
deliberately develop a culture of
tactical and ethical excellence that
reflects the nation we represent
and that draws upon the talents of the
all-volunteer force
who meet the standards of qualification
as a seal blah blah blah etc and so
forth
uh now we should also mention that trump
has come out against this and said that
he wants to reverse it thankfully
whether it's reversed or not though the
fact that the navy seals are even
considering
[Music]
doing gender-neutral language is lunacy
and let's start with the simple fact
that no woman has ever
been a navy seal no woman in history has
ever been able to endure the physical
demands to become a navy seal it's never
happened
and not for lack of trying so at a
minimum
maybe we should wait until a woman
actually manages to become a seal before
we
consider changing the language for this
hypothetical woman it doesn't even exist
also spokesman stroup said uh said you
know this is part of the the ethical
excellence no it's exactly the opposite
this is capitulation
it is surrender to the pc culture it is
precisely the opposite
of what you want to see from the navy
seals this is not ethical excellence
oh yeah we're caving we're caving to the
demands of um
screeching purple-haired feminists
because it's it's ethically
excellent it's the ethically excellent
thing to do
no you know you got to be able to
withstand an assault from the feminists
because these are the people that are
out the navy seals are out in
god forsaken corners of the of the world
going against the baddest of bad guys
so they should be able to withstand uh
you know an attack from
gender studies majors and they can of
course the actual navy seals can but
they're not the ones making these
decisions this is coming from
bureaucrats
who continue to do everything they can
to ruin everything that's good about
america
all right number three here's something
extremely disturbing the parents of one
of the
the kids were killed in in the parkland
shooting in 2018
they've teamed up with an activist group
and come up with an
ai version of their dead son
so that he the dead son the the ai
could deliver an anti-gun message like i
said extremely disturbing
here it is i am patricia oliver
and this is my husband manuel two years
ago our beautiful son joaquin
was shot and killed at parkland
every day i think about him and what his
last moments
must have been like meanwhile
every day nearly hundred more families
lose someone they love to go on violence
every single day we keep telling people
it doesn't have to be like this
they don't listen so we found a way to
bring back someone
that no one will ignore it's very hard
for me to look at this
so please please listen to what our son
has to say
[Music]
yo it's me it's guac
been gone for two years and nothing's
changed bro
people are still getting killed by guns
what is that everyone knows it but they
don't do anything
i'm tired of waiting for someone to fix
it
the election in november is the first
one i could have voted in
but i'll never get to choose the kind of
world i wanted to live in
so you've got to replace my vote okay i
can't watch any more of that that
that uh i cannot fathom
using my child like that
i can't fathom using my child for
political messages
you know even as my child is alive
uh much less when they've died
tragically
in doing this it's
i i'm not even going to continue i think
i'll just i'll just leave it at that
number four
the u.n um actually u.n women that's the
group because
women need their own u.n it seems un is
the united nations
women apparently aren't part of nations
so they need their own u.n
um and that's where un women comes in
and it's good that you and women exist
because we need them for stuff like this
here's the tweet from un women
uh it says you can avoid being a
mansplainer by asking yourself these
questions
did she indicate any desire to hear this
information
is it possible that she knows more about
this topic than i do
did i read the room before starting to
speak
and then it offers a helpful explanation
of mansplaining or definition rather
definition is the practice of a man
explaining something to a woman
in a way that shows he thinks he knows
and understands more than she does
like i said this is good mansplaining is
certainly one of the great threats
facing the world you know we used to
think it was terrorism nuclear holocaust
global conflict war disease famine no
it's none of that it's mansplaining
a man might explain something to a woman
and the woman might get her feelings
hurt by the explanation and that's the
problem that is the real
nuclear holocaust if you will that we
that we all face now of course you read
these questions and you think
okay has any woman ever in her life
asked herself any of those questions
before speaking
especially did he indicate any desire to
hear this information
i mean you tell me ladies have you ever
asked yourself that question before
saying something to a man has any wife
especially
ever in the history of marriage asked
herself that question before saying
something to her husband
if wives did 95 of marital communication
would disappear overnight
so this is another example of feminists
blaming men for something that women
are certainly the primary culprits of
feminists do this a lot i've talked
about it before um but the whole idea
that
men are the ones talking too much
that's just what is this opposite day it
it's
it's it's mind-boggling i might as well
claim
that women are the main ones in a
marriage guilty of clogging up the
drains
from their beard clippings you know that
that's primarily a woman
problem i might it's as absurd and
granted you know there might be some
women with
luscious beards who clog up drains i'm
not judging i mean good for you
if you are a woman with a beard like
that but statistically this is probably
more of a man problem
just as mansplaining ironically is
actually more of a woman problem
than it is a man thing okay number five
finally um
there was a rally over the weekend i
think this is in miami
pro-trump rally and uh anyway here's
what happened
watch
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
yes uh they were barking like dogs just
so you're not confused
those were if you're listening on the
audio podcast
that's so you had two leftist women
um and they were wearing their masks you
know they're being very
so very socially conscious in that way
wearing the masks and they were at this
protest they were
i guess counter protesting by barking in
the faces of the trump supporters
and that was what you saw there that was
basically twitter in real life people
say that twitter isn't real life no
that's that's it that's twitter right
there that's what twitter is
but really for me the most perplexing
thing about this when i watch a video
like this is that
there were two of them you know because
what that tells me you got two women
barking
what that tells me is that either
this was spontaneous and one of them
started barking
and the other one saw it and went wow
that's a good idea i think i'll do the
same
or they talked about it ahead of time
and planned out like they planned this
to go there and bark like dogs
they had a conference and and one of
them said hey
you know what we should do we should go
to this trump protest
and uh no listen to this listen bark
like dogs
yeah bark in their faces that's what we
should do and the other one said
i like it i'm in let's do it either way
whatever
however that happened however that
developed whatever the genesis was of
that
um it's it fascinates me i'm absolutely
fascinated
by it and you know there are many other
words i could use besides fascinated but
we'll go with fascinated
all right we're gonna get to our daily
cancellation just a second but
in case you didn't get enough politics
last week this wednesday october 7th
will be the vice presidential debate
between mike pence camille harris
and it's going to be hosted by me god
help us all
for some reason i'm just as confused as
you are but i'm the guy for this one
i'll be
live reacting to the um debate
as part of a uh live reacting well it's
good i'll be alive
what's it it says live reacting
as opposed to dead reacting how else if
i'm reacting i must be
i don't understand that but anyway i'll
be reacting to today's part of a special
edition of all access live
so members you know you could join me
wednesday night at 8 30 p.m eastern 5 30
p.m pacific at dailywire.com
to live chat on the stream and in the
comments if you're not a part of the
daily wire already
what the hell is wrong with you you
disgraceful scumbag
join us now at all access become an
all-access member get 20
off with code debate so you can watch
all of our upcoming debate coverage
live at dailywire.com apple tv or the
roku
app and you can join us on all access
live every night for online
live stream discussions by the way it
did not say in my copy here to call you
a disgraceful scumbag i just want to
i just want to uh uh disclaimer
don't blame the daily that was me that's
a little bit of ad clipping
they tell me to ad-lib on these things
and then they regret it when they do
because that's what you get
this wednesday october 7th at 8 30 pm
eastern 5 30pm
5 30 pm civic join us now and get 20 off
your all access membership with code
debate
when you sign up today all right i think
that went well what do you think let's
get to our
daily cancellation okay for day for our
daily cancellation today a short one i
went a little bit long in the opening i
had a lot to say there so here's an
update on a story
that i've been following for months a
few others in media have been following
it to not not very many others
this is this is one that the media
wanted us to forget about as soon as it
became obvious that the evidence wasn't
forthcoming to support the claim i refer
to althea bernstein
she's the biracial woman who claimed
that she was attacked by flame-throwing
racist white men in madison wisconsin
the daily wire has the latest we talked
about you know earlier the
inevitabilities
of life and well here's another one this
this was inevitable
madison wisconsin police dropped an
investigation into alleged hate crime
against an 18 year old biracial woman on
friday
after finding little evidence to
corroborate the woman's story
althea bernstein told police in june
that she was attacked by a group of
four white men while stopped at a light
in madison
local police partnered with the fbi and
u.s district attorney scott blader of
the western district of wisconsin to
investigate the case so you've got
this is a federal and local
investigation they've all
they've come together to investigate
this the madison police department
closed this investigation on friday
after spending significant resources
looking into bernstein's claim
investigators were not able to establish
that the alleged attack
ever occurred this from the police the
police department said in a statement
after an exhaustive probe detectives
were unable to corroborate or locate
evidence consistent with what was
reported
blader's office issued a similar
statement saying that the case could not
move forward for
quote lack of evidence like i said this
is shocking
shocking stuff uh it says in a statement
after a thorough investigation to the
events of june 24
2020 including extensive interviews
exhaustive review of traffic and
surveillance video
expert review of digital and forensic
evidence federal investigators determine
that there is insufficient evidence to
prove that a violation of any federal
criminal statute occurred
that's the u.s attorney's office that's
what they said further further after
reviewing all available evidence
authorities could not establish that the
attack as alleged by the complainant
had occurred accordingly the federal
investigation into this incident has
been closed based on the lack of
evidence
now this is very telling bernstein's
family released a three-sentence
statement through the police department
thanking officials for their work
this is their statement althea bernstein
and her family
appreciate the detailed investigative
efforts by
all involved in the case althea's
injuries are healing and the support of
our community has been invaluable in
that regard
we continue to maintain our family
privacy and will not be granting
interviews at this time
okay so you notice how the family
they're not calling for more
investigation they're not chastising the
police for failing to apprehend the
dangerous gang of neo-nazis
a gang that again to remind you
according to bernstein accosted her at a
stoplight
doused her with lighter fluid and then
set her face on fire
you know this is the kind of thing
that'd be very easy to prove if it
didn't if it did in fact happen
there were surveillance videos
everywhere in the city like they said
they were
checking the surveillance videos she
said it happened in the middle of the
street at a stoplight
chances are the attack itself would be
on camera but even if it wasn't surely
there would be
footage of the white guys walking down
the street holding the lighter fluid and
lighter
unless these dudes repel down from
helicopters right into a specific spot
where no cameras can can can see it
carried out the attack and then used
like grappling hooks like batman to
escape
running across the rooftops short of
something like that
they would be on camera yet no cameras
noticed them
nor did any witnesses apparently notice
them
that's because it would appear they
never existed
uh and it's rather easy to not be
noticed when you don't exist
now it's it's a common saying that
absence of evidence is not evidence of
absence
but actually sometimes it is and the
absence of evidence of the
torch-wielding
racists is very very compelling evidence
of their absence
yet the police will not be charging
bernstein with a crime for following
filing a false police report wasting law
enforcement resources
the media outlets that promoted this
claim will not print retractions or even
acknowledge the latest development
and the blm activists who use this case
as evidence of the alleged
scourge of white supremacy will not
apologize
or even give us so much as a you know oh
wait never mind
forget about that one there will be no
consequence of any kind
for any of the people involved in
promoting this story
a story that was obviously extremely
extremely
dubious from the get-go and all that
means of course is that we're going to
get more
dubious stories which is by design
so everyone involved here
is of course rightfully needfully
canceled that'll do it for today thanks
for watching
thanks for listening godspeed
the matte wall show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producers are mathis
glover and robert sterling
our technical producer is austin stevens
edited by danny d'amico
and our audio is mixed by robin
fenderson the matt wall show is a daily
wire production copyright daily wire 20
20.
president trump emerges from the
hospital the mainstream media try to
paralyze you with fear
and president trump gets a bump in the
polls check it out on the michael
knowles show